notre série de portraits avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 rencontre ce midi
avec Salif Traoré il a quitté la Côte
d'Ivoire il y a 4 ans pour venir en
France il travaille dans une
maroquinerie et aussi bénévole au
Secours Catholique
malgré tous ses efforts pour s'intégrer
il est toujours menacé d'expulsion il
s'est confié à bombe à Guy et Clément Le
Calvé
c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20
ans de 1000 ans c'est bien
[Musique]
Bonjour je m'appelle Salif Traoré j'ai
20 ans je travaille dans la maroquinerie
je suis bénévole au Secours Catholique
de Montbard
on a passé en Côte d'Ivoire j'ai pas
vécu avec mes parents ma mère elle
m'avait confié avec un voisin de notre
famille que j'ai grandi avec le voisin
la qui a décidé de partir de la Côte
d'Ivoire j'ai accepté de partir avec lui
il m'a pas dit où on s'en va en fait
dans les bateaux pour venir en Italie je
me suis fait arrêter à Dijon
ils ont coupé mon travail la maison où
j'ai dormi aussi j'ai perdu la maison
donc voilà
je me suis retrouvé dehors
j'avais rendez-vous à Dijon et que j'ai
fini là-bas je suis allé prendre mon
billet pour rentrer à mon bras j'ai pris
mon billet je suis assis à la gare
j'attends le train il me reste 10
minutes je vois les policiers les
policiers sont rentrés
demander la pièce d'identité ils m'ont
pris dans la voiture
de police
je viens le matin déjà mort le travail
que je dois faire c'est déjà préparé ce
matin tu as range la machine je nettoie
et puis voilà je commence à faire la
coupe
mettre dessus il y a du négatif aussi
donc comme ça la semaine prochaine pour
avoir encore auto augmenter sa
polyvalence au sein de la prépa c'est
bon pour toi je souhaite qu'en fait il
se sent le verre avec nous et que il
évolue et que plus tard il puisse
intégrer d'autres secteurs et qu'il
continue comme ça dans ce que c'est un
bon élément et on écrit pourtant j'ai
déjà dans les vêtements en fait
[Musique]
Salut Didier
c'est très simple c'est pas compliqué
ça va
essaie de l'appeler pour ne pas que ça
soit quoi
très bien salut pour la rencontrer il y
a 2 ans il cherchait faire du bénévolat
il voulait aider les autres donc il a
frappé à notre porte je suis
impressionné parce que quel courage quel
courage de quitter son pays natal le
parcours des migrants le connais c'est
un parcours très difficile très
dangereux
[Musique]
c'est
les vêtements que j'apprends à fabriquer
ici
[Musique]
tu as du talent et tu es ici à mon bah
il fera des bonnes choses